the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so hi everybody I'm Alan Edelman and
helped a little bit to teach this class
last year but happy to see that it's
going great this year so professor
Strang came to teach 1806 some of you
may know the the introductory linear
algebra course and professor Strang came
by and gave this great demonstration
about the row rank equals the column
rank and I'm wondering if you did that
in this class at any time or would they
have seen that it's in the notes well in
in any event just as professor Strang
walked out so here I'll just grab this
this is truly I was actually gonna start
writing the code to do the quadrilateral
but I didn't have enough time you could
see me starting but here's the point
five for the triangle which was easy so
that what's the story with Julia in this
class have they used it a little or a
lot or in the labs you've used Julia but
that was just MATLAB so that was but
okay so so so professor Strang showed
this proof where he would he put down a
three by three matrix it had rank two
and he showed the you know took the
columns that were you know the first two
columns were independent and and was
easy you know it was easy to show the
row rank equals the column rank after
professor Strang Roy went out I asked
would that work for the zero matrix so
so here's the the zero matrix and since
I'm not really telling you the proof
I'll just say if I were to put a mate if
I were to make a matrix of the literally
independent columns of this matrix what
would I do
so it's zero sort of a might seem tricky
it's not really that tricky but this is
what I did the moment you walked out so
so yeah so I've got this three by three
matrix and I need to make a first step
in and whatever the proof was I needed
to take the columns of the the literally
independent columns of this matrix and
place them in a matrix of their own what
would I do it would be an empty matrix
what would be the size of this empty
matrix not exactly zero by zero because
where every every column is still in our
three you see so the right answer I hope
this makes sense is a three by zero
empty matrix and that's a concept that
exists in MATLAB and in Julia and in
Python I think I'm sure and in any
computer language so if you had a full
rank 3x3 matrix the linearly independent
columns would be three by three if you
had a rank two would be three by two
they've had a rank one matrix it'd be
three by one so if I had no columns
three by zero makes sense and to finish
the proof again I'm not telling these
students it's in the notes apparently
the next matrix would be R and of zero
three and of course you multiply and you
get a three by three matrix of zeros so
it's fun to see that that proof still
works even for the zero matrix without
any real age so that was just today um
let me the other thing is let me can I
say a word or two about recent stuff
about Julia so I start to put together a
talk it's not really ready yet but I'll
share it with you anyway so Google did
the Julia world a big favor last week I
mean this is huge so you all know
machine learning is hot that's probably
why you're here in this class I probably
don't have to tell you and yet I
wouldn't be surprised if a number of you
were sort of wish the whole this whole
class was in Python or something or
maybe MATLAB or so I don't doubt that
some of you might have wanted that to
happen and we get sort of bombarded with
with you know why not Python not so much
MATLAB anymore but you know why not
Python is sort of the issue that comes
up a lot and I could talk til the cows
come home but nobody would believe me
but Google came out last week and said
that that when it comes to machine
learning there really are two languages
that are powerful enough to do machine
learning to do machine learning kinds of
things that you want to do and in some
sense the the rest of today's lecture
that I'm going to give will will be
maybe illustrations of this but if you
want you can go and look at their their
blog here
what they do is they basically sort of
start the the race with a whole bunch of
programming languages there's Python
there's our Java JavaScript they they're
you know they they they sort of look at
all of these languages and if you read
the blog you'll see but we're gonna
filter them out on technical merits and
and right away a lot of them disappear
including Python and Java
and and they actually spend if you go to
the blog you'll see they spend a great
deal of time on the Python story because
they know that people are gonna want to
hear that one right I mean if people
want to be convinced and so there's
actually multiple screens full on the
the reason why Python is just not good
enough for machine learning so they they
leave for languages left julia swift c++
and rust and then sort of they the next
sort of part of the if you go to the
next part of of the blog they filter on
usability and then two more so to bite
the dust
so c++ and rust disappeared and then
they go on to say that these are the
only two languages they feel are
appropriate for machine learning and
they put this nice quote you know that
that you know it shares many common
values and they actually go on and about
what machine learning really needs and
you know yeah i'd recommend you look at
it and then finally of course they're
gonna push swift which they which they
should so they had some more blahblah
about more people are using swift maybe
it's true i don't know but so that you
know they're gonna they really said is
they're more familiar with swift and
julia which you know if i if I were
speaking I'd say I'm more familiar than
Julia than Swift so maybe it's fair and
then I started to put a little cartoon
on the psychology of programming
languages just because it's it's sort of
a something that I bump into with all
the time people always say all languages
are equally good it doesn't really
matter but the truth is if you don't
mention a language if you mention a
language that you're not using yet
you're gonna tune it out at least until
Google comes along so that that's where
we are okay enough about I just put this
together I know testing it out on you
all right now so now let me do so two
more mathematical things so the first
thing I want to do is talk to you about
forward mode automatic
differentiation so if you've done any
automatic depreciation of course okay so
I think this is pretty fun I hope you'll
like it
I have a notebook and Julia run forward
mode automatic differentiation and the
this notebook came together because I
was trying to understand what the big
deal was for a long time and and I had a
little trouble I mean it's it's the
usual story we're on a line-by-line
level it's easy to understand but like
what's the big deal part that's that
sometimes the harder thing to grasp and
and and the first notebook I'm gonna
show you is sort of the result of my
trying to grasp like what was the the
real picture here and the second thing I
think I'll just do on the blackboard
it's not even really ready yet but I'll
sort of unleash it on you folks anyway
is to show you how to do a particular
example of backward mode automatically
pronounciation the backpropagation let
you see in a neural net and I I guess
you have seen some their own that's here
so actually they might now everybody's
seen neural nets I think you know two
years from now it'll be in height low
high schools and three years from there
will be in kindergartens I don't know
everybody see neural nets seem to be
sort of they're not that hard to
understand okay so let me let me start
things off and really the two things
that I'd left to convince you of is
let's let me just find here's my ordered
if thing the two things that I really
want to convince you of and maybe you
already believe some of this is one that
well maybe you don't believe this yet
but that the language matters in a
mathematical sense that the right the
right the right computer language can do
more for you than just take some
algorithm on a blackboard and implement
it you could do it could do much more
and this is something that that I hope
to give a few examples of and the other
thing that I bet you all are believed
now because you've been in this class is
that that linear algebra is the basis
for everything every course should start
with linear algebra I mean that's it to
me it feels like a unfortunate accident
of history that that linear algebra came
too late for too many reasons and and so
very often things that would be better
done with linear algebra are
not and and and I mean it if to me it
feels like doing physics without
calculus like I just don't get it
like I know high schools do that but it
just seems wrong you know it to me like
you know all of engineering all it
should all be linear algebra I mean I'm
I just believe that almost all maybe not
all but quite a lot more than most
people realize I would say okay so let
me start with automatic differentiation
so so I'm gonna start by this story by
telling you that I would go to
conferences I would go to numerical
analysis conferences I would hear people
talk about automatic differentiation I'm
gonna be honest I was reading my email I
was tuned out like who cares about like
I know calculus I could you could teach
a computer to do it I don't you know I'm
seems pretty easy to me I mean I'm sure
there are technical details but it
didn't seem that interesting to teach a
computer to differentiate I sort of
figured that it was the same calculus
that I learned when I took a calculus
class you know here you know you you've
memorized this table you teach it to a
computer you know you learn the chain
rule and the product rule and the
quotient rule and bump you you did the
computer is doing just what I would do
it with paper and pencil so a big deal I
was I didn't pay attention and in any
event there was said a little there was
this little neuron in the back of my
brain that said hey maybe I'm wrong
maybe it's doing finite differences you
know the sort of thing where you take
the the the you take the d-y-by-dx in
some numerical way it's you do the
finite differences and in the radical
analysis they're supposed to tell you
you know if H is too big you get
truncation error if you have a t too
small you get roundoff error and the
truth is nobody ever tells you what's a
good age but you go to numerical
analysis class hoping somebody would
tell you but but in any event so I
thought maybe it was that kind of a
numerical finite difference and and and
and I think the big surprise for me was
that automatic differentiation was
neither the first nor the second thing
that there's actually a third thing
something different
that's neither the first or the second
that I found that fascinating and and
maybe I'll even tell you how how it hit
me in the head that this was the story
because I really wasn't paying attention
but I loved the singular value
decomposition I'm glad to see that
people are drawing parabolas and quarter
circles and figuring out what the the
minimum SVD value is this thing right is
is just you know the
it's justyou know God's gift to mankind
it's just a good factorization and one
of the things that I would I was playing
with with with Julia was to calculate
the the Jacobian matrix for the SVD so
so you know all matrix factorizations
are just changes of variables right so
if you have an if you have a square
matrix n by n the SVD babe I'm sure you
know this is you know the the U matrix
is really n times n minus one over two
variables so is the V and the Sigma has
got n variables put it all together you
got N squared so it's just a change of
variables and every time you change
variables you can form that big matrix n
squared by N squared of the you know
dy/dx compute its determinants and get
an answer and and I want you to know
what that I wanted to actually knew the
theoretical answer for that and I wanted
to see a computer confirm that
theoretical answer and I spoke to some
people who who wrote Otto Tiffin in non
giulia languages and I was surprised by
the answer they said oh yeah we could
teach the answer to our system I said
what do you mean you could teach the
answer why doesn't just compute the
answer what you have to teach the answer
I thought that was all wrong because in
Julia we didn't have to teach it it
actually it would actually calculate it
oh and then I started to understand a
little bit more about what auto-da-fé
was doing and what Julia was doing and
so this is how this notebook came to be
so let me start I'm saying too much let
me start with an example that that might
kind of hit home so I'm going to compute
the square root of x I'm a real simple
example you know square roots pretty
easy I'm gonna take when the oldest
algorithms known to mankind
the Babylonians square root algorithm it
says you know start with a starting
guess T maybe it's a little bit too low
for the square root of x get x over T so
that would be too large go ahead and
take the average and repeat okay this is
equivalent to a Newton's method for
taking the square root and you know it's
been known for millennia to mankind so
it's not a terribly you know it's not
the latest research by any means for
computing square roots but it it works
very effectively and here's a little
Julia code that actually will well will
implement it it probably looks like code
in any language so I'm gonna start off
at one so
literally I'm just gonna take one plus
the starting value X and divide by two
and then I'm gonna repeat okay and you
know you can we we can check that the
algorithm works here's alphas PI and so
I'll take the Babylonian algorithm and
compare it to Julie's built-in and you
see it gives gives the right answer here
it is with square root of two you know
always good to check your your code
works okay even I like to see things
graphically so I ran the algorithm for
lots of values of X and you could even I
love doing this I kind of wished that in
the previous talk I was this is what if
I'd only worked fast enough I was
actually I went to build a little gooey
where I could move the points and in
front of your eyes maybe you have one in
MATLAB I bet you do but I wanted to
build it but they didn't get there fast
enough but here this is a sort of thing
and I'd like to see the convergence I
mean so you could see the digits
converging the the the parabola on the
bottom the black is the square root of
course so there it is there's the
Babylonian algorithm I would like to get
the derivative of square root but the
rules of the game are I'm not going to
type method one or method two I'm not
going to do you'll never see me type 1/2
X to the minus 1/2 that's right you all
know that's the derivative I will not
type that I will not it's not gonna come
anywhere from Julia ok and the second
thing is I'm not gonna do a finite
difference all right I'm gonna get that
square root but not by by by sort of
either the two things that I'm sure you
would think of alright but here's how
I'm gonna do it and and I'm gonna do a
little bit of Julia code there'll be
eight lines of Julia but I'm not gonna
completely say how it works yet I'll
I'll keep you in suspense for maybe
about five minutes and then I'll tell
you how it how it works
all right so here's eight lines of Julia
code that will get me the square root so
in these three lines I'm gonna create a
julia type i'm gonna call it a d4 for a
dual number which is a name that goes
back at least a century maybe more so
i'm gonna create a d type and all this
is is a pair of floats okay so um it's a
tuple with a pair of floats it's gonna
be it's going to be some sort of
numerical function and derivative pair
all right so three of my eight lines is
to create a d-- this means enjoy your
language
this means to use a subtype of a number
so we're gonna treat it like a number
right we want to be able to add multiply
and divide these these ordered pairs but
it's just a pair of numbers right don't
get--don't the Julia scare you it's just
a function derivative numerical pair
okay and what's these other five lines
well I want to teach it to some rule in
the quotient rule so you all remember
the sum rule I guess that's the easy one
the quotient rule is still I still have
the my teacher from high school you know
ringing in the back of my ear you know
the denominator times it was the
numerator minus the numerator you all
have that jingle and you're working your
brain too I bet you do divided by the
denominator squared
can't even get it out of my head so up
so so there's the quotient rule and so
what are we doing in these five lines
well first of all I want to overload
plus and divide and a few other things
and Julia wants me to say are you sure
so the way you say are you sure is that
I'm going to import plus and divide you
know because it'd be dangerous to play
with plus so here I'm gonna the plus two
dual numbers we're gonna add the
function and the derivatives divide two
dual numbers we're gonna divide the
function values and denominator times
the numerator blah blah but you get it
okay that's six of the eight lines the
seventh line is if I have a dual number
I wanted to to convert it you know how
like the wheels are embedded in the
complex is you know you just we have to
tell Julia to to take a dual number and
stick a zero in in and then then dual
numbers and regular numbers can complete
nicely together and this this actually
is the thing that actually says if I
have a dual number in a number in
operation promote them so the work as
dual numbers so eight lines of code so
the first thing I'm gonna tell you is
I'm going to remind you you never know I
never typed one-half X to the minus 1/2
do you agree no one I'm not importing
any packages it's not like it's coming
in from the I'm not sneaking it in from
the side
there's no 1/2 X to the minus a house
and there's certainly not any numerical
derivatives either right just the just
just arguably a rule that almost feels
symbolic the quotient rule in the
addition rule but but no numerical
finite differences at all here okay so
so first of all let me show you here
that I'm taking the I'm applying the
Babylonian algorithm without rewriting
code to a dual number now before we
applied it to numbers but now I'm gonna
apply it to this dual number they're
just invented I'm gonna apply it at 49
one cuz I know the answer and then I'm
gonna compare it with I'm taking one
half of a square root of x just for
comparison purposes right and not not in
my own algorithm and of course you see
that I'm getting magically the right
answer without ever so you should wonder
how did I do that how did I get the
derivative we could take any number you
like here's a hundred if you prefer to
see a number like pi we can do that I
mean you know we can do it every like
it's going to work so there you see that
this is the square root of pi and this
would be one half over the square root
of pi numerically so and you see it
matches these these numbers to enough
digits in fact all the digits actually
yeah so this thing magically worked okay
you should all be wondering how did that
happen
right I didn't rewrite any code I
actually wrote a code to just compute a
square root I never could never wrote a
code to compute the derivative of square
roots and and by the way this is a
little bit of the Julia magic that that
we're pushing numerically that very
often and in this world people will
write a code to do something and then if
you wanted to do something more like get
a derivative somebody writes another
code with Julia very often you can
actually keep to the original code if
you just use it properly and
intelligently you can do magic things
without writing new codes and you'll see
this again in a little bit but here's
the derivative of you know this this is
the plot of 1/2 of the square root of x
in black and again you could see the
convergence over here all right well I'm
still not going to show you why it works
just yet I promise I will and it's
probably a few more minutes more but
what I will do first is is I'd like to
show you something that most people
don't ever look at I never look at it I
want to show you here's the same
Babylonian code I want to show you the
assembler for the computation of the
derivative so I'm gonna run Babylonian
on a dual dual number and we're gonna
look here and I don't know if anybody
here reads assembler I'm betting there's
zero or one of you actually
reads this stuff how many of you read
assembler okay we have got it wasn't 0-1
we had a half right there's a half he's
kind of going like this here's the arrow
here's one he's like this okay
so so I think zero ones like the right
bit but I'll bet you'll believe me if I
tell you that when you have short
assembler like this and it's not very
long then you have efficient code but
it's very tight it'll run very fast
so whatever this thing is doing it's
short and this you won't get from any
other language if you did try to do the
same thing in Python I promise you
they'll be screens and screens and
screens full of stuff if even if you
could get it so so here's the Babylonian
algorithm on the dual number and here it
is an assembler and it's short so so the
other thing I'm saying is not only does
it work but Julie also makes it
efficient so before I finally tell you
what's really going on and why it works
I'm gonna grab a Python symbolic package
which will work nicely with Julia and
I'm going to run the same code through
the Python symbolic and show you what
the these are the iterations that you
get so this is a Khaleesi the the
iterations towards the square root and
here are the iterations of the
derivative that's actually being
calculated um and the key point here is
of course we're not this is a symbolic
computation we're not doing a symbolic
computation this is mathematically
equivalent to the function we would get
if we were to like plot it or something
but of course we're not symbolic
computation is very inefficient I mean
you get these big coefficients I mean
look at this number what is this five
million or something anyway you get
these big numbers these people even
bigger numbers here look at these huge
numbers right the it takes a lot of
storage I'm dragging these X's along
there's a big drag on memory I mean this
is not the way that this is why we do
numerical computation but what the
Babylonian algorithm in the absence of
any roundoff is equivalent to computing
you know above the line it's computing
the square root here and then below here
this is these are the iterates towards
the derivative so it's not actually
calculating X 1/2 X to the minus 1/2
it's actually doing something iterative
that is approximating 1/2
- all right well let me tell you now let
me sort of reveal what's going on just
so that I can kind of show you how it's
getting the answer and like I said it
was the SVD that sort of convinced me
how this was happening cuz the SVD is
also an iterative algorithm like this
Babylonian square root but but it's
easier to show you the point with the
baloney and square root so I'm gonna do
something that I would never want to do
which is explicitly write a derivative
Babylonian algorithm and what I'm doing
is I'm gonna take the derivative spec 2x
of every line of my code so you know if
every even or odd line I never know
what's even or odd anymore but the
original line of code had one flex over
two now I'm going to take the derivative
or get 1/2 here
I had this line of code if I take the
derivative I'll use the the the the
quotient rule and this would be the
derivative if I run this code what I'm
effectively doing is I'm just using good
old plus and times and divide nothing
fancy there's not a square root to be
seen but what I'm doing is as I run my
algorithm I'm also running I'm actually
computing the derivative as I go so if I
have this infinite algorithm it's going
to converge to the square root this the
derivative algorithm will converge to
the derivative of the square roots but
I'm not I'm not using anything other
than plus minus times and divide to make
that happen so if you rewrite any code
at all you could have any code iterative
finite it doesn't matter if you just
take the derivatives back to your
variable of every line of your code then
you can get a derivative out and as I
said it's not a symbolic derivative like
you know all of 1801 or whatever
wherever we teach calculus these days
and it's not a numerical derivative like
in a numerical courses that you know the
18.3 a X Y Z's whatever it's a different
beast it's the it's it's using the the
quotient rule in the addition rule at
every step of the way to get the answer
so and you know here's this d-bob
learning algorithm you could see it
running and I'll get it gives the right
answer I have to execute the code first
to get the right answer but you see it
gives it gives the right answer okay oh
I was just in Istanbul and I they could
challenge me to do sign I forgot about
that it's still in the Summa notebook I
it in front of everybody it worked I got
a cosign okay but let me pass all of
that so so so so let me go back and tell
you then how is this all working well
what's happening let's go back to the
eight lines of code and now maybe you
could see what's happening the where's
my eight lines of code from the very
beginning and I could have watched the
time I want to show you this one other
thing too so hopefully I'll have enough
time to do that but here let's see we
were mighty Atlantic code where are they
here we go you're here the events of
code so what I'm doing is instead of
rewriting all your code by taking the
derivative of every line the human way
I'm saying that why can't the software
just do this in some automatic way and
this is where the automatic
differentiation comes in and in the old
old days when people in all the
numerical code was in Fortran there
would be these source-to-source
translators that would actually input
code and output derivatives of code the
giulia way the more modern way is to let
the JIT compiler kind of do that for you
so here I need it plus and divide of
course I would want to add minus and
times but you just add a couple of
things and then bump the you know you
don't have to rewrite the D Babylonian
because the Babylonian with this type
will just will do the work for you okay
and that's where the magic of a good
piece of software will have it so you
don't have to write a translator you
don't have to handwrite it you just give
sort of the rules and you let the
computer do it right I mean that's what
computers are supposed to be good at and
so that's that's what's happening all
right so that's that's forward mode
automatic differentiation I've got 10
minutes to go backwards so but let me
see if there's any anybody have any
questions about this this it's really
magic right but it's pretty wonderful
magic and and and you know I don't know
what you've heard about machine learning
but to be honest
machine learning these days it's it's
it's it's you know forgetting about
whether you know humans will be useless
which I don't believe by the way but but
the the the the big thing about machine
learning is that it's really just a big
optimization that's all it is right
big minimum/maximum problem where you've
all known from calculus that what you
need to do is take derivatives you know
set them to zero right you know in the
case of multivariate it's a gradient you
set it to zero and so really all of this
machine learning all the big stories and
everything in the end comes down to a
automatic differentiation is sort of
like the the workhorse of the whole
thing and so if we could have a a
language that gives you that workhorse
in a good way then machine learning
really sort of benefits from that so so
I hope you all see the the big picture
of machine learning it really does come
down to taking derivatives that that's
that's the end of that's how you
optimize any quick questions otherwise
I'm gonna switch topics and I'm going to
move to the blackboard yeah there's a
trick that basically lets you go to
higher orders yeah you can basically
make it a combo of two first order
derivatives so yeah it can be done did
you have a question oh we're using for
using types so so it's the biggest trick
in the world it's not this little thing
the idea of making a type to do what you
did you see chroniker products in this
class what no okay um let me see what
what would you have seen in this yeah
did you see tridiagonal matrices your
favorite okay so here so here's a
built-in type let's say n is it doesn't
have to be four I'm gonna create a
Strang matrix if I could spell it right
and it's going to be a sim tri diagonal
which is a julia type and we will create
two x ones of N and minus ones of n
minus one now here's a type I mean this
is built-in but you could have created
it yourself just as easily and I don't
like calling
this it's certainly not a dense matrix
and I don't like calling it a sparse
matrix I prefer to call it a structured
matrix though the word sparse it's a
little tricky here but the reason why I
don't like to call this a sparse matrix
is because we're not storing indices in
any I mean there's a lot of fancy
schemes for storing indices for for
sparse matrices well the score store is
a diagonal vector there's the two's on
the diagonal there's a four vector with
four twos and here's a three vector for
the off diagonal and you know you don't
have it twice by the way most sparse
matrix structures would would would
would have you know the the minus ones
vector twice the super and the sub but
really only the quarter information
that's needed is stored and in a way one
uses types in julia to basically you
only store what you need not more and
then you define your operations to work
so for example if i were to take you
know Strang inverse time so anything
with here's you know terms of random for
I'm gonna do a linear solve you would
want to use a special back Slav that
knew that the matrix was a symmetric
tri-diagonal so it's a big story of
being able to create types and use them
for your own purposes without you know
any wastage and this is a sort of thing
that while you can do it in languages
like Python in MATLAB if you were table
look at the assembler and that level
never let you Python you just would
regret it but you would you would see
just how much overhead there is in doing
this so there'd be no performance gain
but in a way what this is what you want
to do you want to use these things to
match the mathematics and and so that's
really the nice thing to be able to do
all right I only have five minutes I
don't know if I'm gonna pull this off
but I'll let me see if I could give you
the main idea in five minutes of her
immersed mode differentiations but here
as long as you are familiar with neural
networks let me see if I can do this
very quickly I'm going to start with
scalars okay I'm gonna do a neural
network of all scalars but only for
simplicity for starters but I think
you're gonna see that this can general
two vectors and matrices which are real
neural networks so what I'm going to do
is I want to imagine that we have our
inputs will have a bunch of scalar
weights and biases so here's w1 and I'll
go up to W and B all right so we have a
bunch of weights and biases here okay
and we'll also have an x1 which will
sort of start off our neural network and
we're going to compute I'll write in
sort of Julia like or MATLAB black
notation for I equals 1 through n I will
update X by taking some function of my
current input maybe something like this
and what function H to use I don't
really care too much in the old days
people used to talk about the sigmoid
function nowadays it's the maximum of 0
and T that gets used all the time it's
got this ridiculous name rel U which I I
really can't stand but anyway they
rectified linear unit but in any event I
mean it it it's just a function that's
you know T of T is greater than equal to
0 0 if not so so but whatever function
and you like and here I'm just gonna
update Taemin ultimately you might also
have some data Y and you would like to
if everything is a scalar like I said
this could be generalized pretty quickly
but what we can do is we we can minimize
say 1/2 Y minus X M squared you know in
the you're going to want to find the
data that would minimize that ok all
this generalizes to matrices and vectors
which is what most neural nets do ok and
since since since I'm not going to have
a lot of time maybe I can just sort of
cut to the chase if I were to
differentiate the key line here I've got
a little bit of Julia here but if I were
to differentiate the key line what would
I write I would write well here actually
let me use the
usual notation let me have Delta IB the
H prime of WX i plus bi okay so that's
that's Delta I and then you can see that
DX I plus one is Delta I and I'll have
DWI X I plus D X I WI plus d bi would be
the differential this would be how how
I'm almost done that's the goodness so
if I make a little change I like to
think of this as like point 0:01 changes
I don't like I don't like infinitesimal
said like point O once it's how I think
of them but you make a little change
here a little change here a little
change here you get a change here you
you'll get this you know you'll get this
linear this linear function of the
perturbations here gives you perturb
ations here ok well I've only got one
minute so I'm gonna write all this out
with linear algebra because everything
is better when written out with linear
algebra so I'm gonna write down that I'm
gonna write down that I'm actually
interested in the last element but dxd n
plus 1 is going to equal and I'm gonna
have a couple of matrices here let me
just sort of get the structure right
this will be T X 2 DX n plus 1 again
sorry for the squishing okay but and
here in fact I'd like to use block
matrices a little bit so here I'm gonna
have DW 1 DB 1 I'm gonna put the bias
together sorry for the mess but and DW
and DB n Julia lets you make block
matrices and you can actually use them
directly there'd be a special type right
there okay and then what goes here you
could actually see what it would be
would be I hope I'm doing it right but
there'd be a delta 1 X 1 and Delta and X
N and this would be a diagonal matrix
okay and then what do I have over here
here I'd have the Delta WS and if you
check you'll see that this will be I'm
not gonna get the indices right and I
don't have time so I'm just gonna write
it like this and now I'm just going to
give you the end of the story
at a time you could write all this as DX
is equal to a diagonal matrix times the
derivative of the parameters plus a
lower triangular matrix times D X again
and so if you want to solve this linear
algebra just does the back propagation
you have I minus L DX is d DP or DX will
be I minus L inverse D DP and if I only
want the last element let's say E and as
the vector that pulls out the last
element then this is all I'm going to
need to get all my derivatives and
what's the moral of the story I
apologize for going one minute over but
the moral the story is instead of back
propagating through your own hard work
you probably know that when you solve a
lower triangular matrix people over a
written code that backhauls the lower
triangular matrix the back the big back
piece has already been implemented for
you why do it why reinvent the wheel in
back propagation at the back of linear
algebra already has the back you see I
mean so if you just do this and you do
it in a language to let you get full
full performance you don't need to do
your own back propagation because a
simple backslash will do it for you so I
apologize for going over I know if
professor Strang got some final words
but but anyway the linear algebra is a
secret to everything that's that's the
big message
[Applause]
since it's our last two minutes or minus
two minutes of 1806 five let me just I
hope you guys enjoyed it I certainly
enjoyed as you could tell teaching this
class seeing how it would go and writing
about it
so I'll let you know was about the
writing and meanwhile I'll get your
writing on the projects which I
appreciate very much and of course
grades are going to come out well and I
hope you've enjoyed it so thank you all
right thanks
[Applause]